seguiré siendo primera ministra hasta
que se elija un sucesor
y para definir el sucesor de listross el
partido conservadora elegido la vía
rápida después de las largas semanas de
campaña con múltiples candidatos esta
vez el umbral de patrocinios para ser
considerados se fija muy alto
los candidatos deben ser nominados por
al menos 100 diputados
el partido conservador tiene 357
diputados en la cámara lo que significa
que habrá un máximo de tres candidatos
entonces quién podría presentarse para
tomar la cabeza del partido mayoritario
en la cámara de los comunes y por lo
tanto ser nombrado Primer Ministro
primero los que perdieron con listros el
exministro de Hacienda elegido por los
parlamentarios Pero no por los miembros
del partido es el primero en haber
reunido los 100 apoyos Penny morton que
quedó en tercer lugar en las últimas
elecciones actual ministra de relaciones
con el parlamento cuenta con poco más de
finalmente Boris Johnson varios
parlamentarios conservadores ya están
haciendo campaña por él y el actual
ministro de energía incluso lanzó la
etiqueta Boris o nada en Twitter el día
clave es el lunes los diputados
realizarán una primera votación para
eliminar a uno de los tres candidatos
luego votan el mismo día para nominar a
su candidato preferido a título
indicativo eso significa que o el que
llega segundo se retira o una vez más
los miembros del partido conservador
votarán al final de la próxima semana el
nombre del nuevo Primer Ministro
británico se conocerá a más tardar el
próximo viernes 28 de octubre